combien de temps
combien de temps allons-nous continuer
continuez à croire que 100 blessés
graves par jour ça n'est pas si grave
que ça
continuez à croire que réparer les corps
peut suffire à réparer les vies
continuez à croire que ceux qui
survivent pourront revivre comme avant
continue à croire qu'un accident de la
route ne dure qu'une seconde
alors qu'il peut durer toute une vie
continuez à croire que derrière chaque
corps blessés il n'y a qu'une seule vie
blessés
continue à croire que les accidents de
la route sont une fatalité alors que
c'est à nous d'agir pour les éviter
rendre la route plus sûre ne dépend que
de nous
merci à marius sébastien cyril alan
maryse franck aurélien et à leur
entourage pour leur participation à ce
film mobilisons-nous à leurs côtés